( bright techno music)
- Oh!
(woman grunting)
(woman screams)
(upbeat pop music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together seven black belts.
- I am a black belt.
- I'm a black belt.
- I am a black belt
- I am a black belt.
- [Narrator] Two of them are liars.
If the group discovers both liars
they'll split a cash prize.
If any of the liars survives,
they win the entire prize.
Who is the odd one out?
- No
- I guess we'll do it real
quick. The most generic thing.
How long everybody's been training,
what your martial artist?
We can just go straight down the line.
- My name's Andre, I've been
training for eight years.
I do TaeKwonDo.
- I'm Jessica.
And I also do TaeKwonDo
for about a decade.
More than that.
- My name's Keith Hudson,
and I've been training
for six years now in karate and TaeKwonDo.
- My name is Victoria.
I've been training for
like over 10 years now
and I do Kajukenbo.
I came on here to like bring
representation to the style.
- Adriana, been doing it for like 15 years
TaeKwonDo, third degree.
- My name is Casey.
I have been doing Hapkido for nine years.
- My name is Anthony Cruz.
And I've been doing Jiu
Jitsu for about 10 years.
A lot of TaeKwonDo people, huh?
- I know.
- Yeah I wasn't expecting that.
- What got you all into martial arts?
- I played a lot of
fighting games as a kid, so
(punching noise imitation)
hitting stuff, uh one
day I kicked the table
Madre was furious, she was like,
"we have to take this
energy somewhere else."
And the next day she, he
enrolled me in TaeKwonDo dojo.
- When we were all line Andre was talking
to himself and I think he was going
over his head to make sure
he's not gonna miss a cue.
- Lot of Jackie Chan growing up.
And I was like, I wanna join in like
karate like but not Kung Fu.
- My dad was a black belt.
I got indoctrinated when I was five. Go.
- My dad put me in it to
like learn self defense.
- My dad did Aikido when I was younger
and I said that I wanted to be like him.
- Dad didn't want me to be a ballerina
so that's why he put me in Hapkido.
- I loved MMA and the UFC.
I wanna have a better understanding of it.
So I got into Jiu Jitsu.
(bell rings)
(upbeat hiphop music begins)
- A little too specific
with the lamp story
which is kind of a dead giveaway
when people are lying.
- I felt like Anthony was suspicious
because the way he was like
instigating the conversation.
(upbeat hiphop music continues)
- Aww
- Aww, bye bye
- Bye bye Andre.
- Aww
- I'm gonna talk fighting
games with you later.
- [Narrator] This is round
two, the martial arts round.
You will each have about 30 seconds to
demonstrate your martial arts and prove
to the others that you are a black belt.
- Anything
- I'm not gonna throw it. Don't worry.
- [Narrator] Okay. All right, all right.
(Adriana's fighting sounds)
(rock music begins)
(rock music ends)
(Adriana screams)
(everyone clapping)
- That was so bad. I'm sorry.
(calm upbeat music)
- Ha!
(calm music ends)
- Her form seemed kind of like basic.
And I thought since she did like TaeKwonDo
she would do like a
lot of kicks and stuff.
- Okay. So I'm gonna talk as
if I'm teaching a normal class.
Can you come into, this is
called a garden jujitsu.
It's one of the most, it's one
of the martial arts that
teaches you how to be offensive
on the ground.
I'm gonna teach you what's
called a triangle choke
and to do a triangle choke
It's a very, it's a
very fundamental process
but you use it from white to black belt.
- He showed a jujitsu move
and it seemed like very rehearsed.
And it was something that
anyone could essentially learn
that if they went to a couple classes
or trained a little bit in jujitsu
- Boom, and I lock up
here and now I have this
my leg go across the neck
pull the head down and pitch
my hips up and that's it.
And if he doesn't tap, he
goes to sleep in six seconds.
(tribal drum music begins)
(Casey's fighting sounds)
- Get him sis!
- Oh!
- Not the hair!
(Tribal drum music ends)
- Gone! He's gone!
(everyone clapping)
- Fatality.
(Bamboo flute playing)
- He yah!
He yah!
- Oo!
(everyone clapping)
- It's still on
- That was so cool!
- Permission to break?
- Permission granted sir.
(Keith breathes deeply)
(tense music)
- He yah!
(Keith breathes deeply)
(upbeat music begins)
- Even though it's super impressive,
I have a lot of friends that
have learned how stop spin.
Saber Spin. They're stunt actors,
but they're not black belts.
(upbeat hiphop music continues)
- He just did a basic demonstration.
And he even used the
words, "Everyone uses this
from white belt all the
way up to black belt."
Did I think he did jujitsu? Absolutely.
Did I think he was a black belt? No.
(upbeat hiphop music continues)
(upbeat hiphop music ends)
- Can we clap?
- Oh
(woman googles)
- I wish I had a great hair like that.
- [Narrator] Everyone feels
confident that you already
caught the mole, you can end the game now.
But if the majority has
doubt, the game will continue.
Please raise your hand
if you wanna continue playing the game.
- Because I have respect
for you, I am the mole.
- Huh? What?
(Casey giggles)
- I am not a black belt.
Not yet, but I want to be,
and I don't feel comfortable
deceiving any of you guys.
You guys are fantastic and I can't lie.
I can't.
So I humbly apologize.
And I'm sorry for deceiving you guys.
- That sounds legit?
- Oh no
- Is it?
- [Narrator] You guys
still have four minutes.
- Okay.
(everyone talking)
- I was just gonna ask for
proper sidekick technique.
- That's what I was gonna do!
- I haven't done it in ten years so
honestly I could never even do a sidekick
- I kind of suspected it cuz
you're super martial arts nerd.
- Yeah.
- But like, I, I don't mean that
in like a bad way, but I was
like, he's so nerdy about it.
Like I feel like he's kind of fresh ish.
- So where are you at now?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. But belt are you?
- Tell us the whole story.
- I just got my first
advanced belt in the summer.
I trained during the pandemic.
I started training back
in martial arts in 2019.
I was a smoker and a
drinker through my twenties
and I needed to turn my life around and
(crying sounds)
- Oh got it, got it.
- Breathe, breathe.
- It's the pain coming.
- I wanted to be honest.
I felt it here.
This game is fun
and I didn't mean to just, you know,
- You're good.
- Just give up.
But You guys are so good
and you inspire me
and I can't lie to the
people who inspire me.
(bell rings)
(somber music)
- Respect that.
- [Narrator] Again, we do have two moles.
So please raise your hand
if you want to continue playing the game.
Starting now, for every time
all of you vote out someone
that is not the mole,
the prize money will be reduced by half.
- The only reason I want to
continue is you did say like
I haven't, as soon as I mentioned
like sidekick technique, like, oh
I haven't done it a long
time so I don't know
- Honestly, I could
never even do a side kick
- The form was like a very basic kind
of color belt form
because, and in TaeKwonDo
- Oh, in my, in my studio
it's second degree.
- Wait, what's your style though?
- My style?
Oh shoot.
Like, honestly, like it
was never explained to me.
My master was never the most professional.
- I just think when Victoria
asked you what style you did
it did take you a while to, to respond
cuz it's just right
away "Oh, I do Hapkido."
If you're a black belt
you can easily explain
how to do a sidekick.
- Yeah.
- Sidekick is a basic kick.
- It is but my kick was
never as good as the others.
- No, no, no, it doesn't
matter the height.
As long as you can.
- It's like muscle memory.
That was good.
- Yeah. So the biggest
thing is really just
like explaining technique.
You know what I mean?
Cuz like there's people that
I've met that are literally
like they're blind, they're
paralyzed, whatever.
- Yeah
- And they can teach and they
can explain the technique down
to a T if that makes sense to me.
- Yeah
- You know what I mean?
- No, that makes sense.
- So it's just like, it's
not to be like offensive
or anything
- Yeah of course no, no, no.
- No, it's just, you know what I mean?
- Just thinking.
It's just things that
like that we think of.
- Yeah, no you're pinpointing them out
and like I honestly thought
that all of y'all really pretty real
and I thought we caught Andre
and Keith and like the guys
I thought they were the moles, you know
we're all professional in a sense.
(bell rings)
I'm not too sure of Victoria's
technique cuz I'm not.
I like, I don't have
any knowledge of that.
- I felt bad because
like we attacked Jessica
but I asked her what
martial art style she did.
And she like stuttered
and she didn't know.
And I was like, isn't that why we're here?
(everyone whispering)
- I'm sorry.
- It's okay.
I understand.
It's a game y'all it's a game.
- [Narrator] Please raise your hand.
If you want to continue
you playing the game.
If the lights are green,
that means you have voted
out the mole and you win.
If the lights turn red
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
- Yay!
- Oh! Good job.
- Good job.
Real black belts
- [Narrator] Will the
fake black belts, both,
please step forward and
reveal yourselves in
- 3,
2,
1.
- Okay.
(everyone talking)
- Oh!
- My dad was a black belt
and when we were young
he put me in the school
in Sherwood, Arkansas,
Danny Dring's Living
Defense Martial Arts dojo.
- Yeah. So I do martial arts.
I've like I'm self taught with
like weapons and everything.
I do Mo Thai, like formally.
That's like the formal thing that I do.
- The punches in the beginning, it was
- Yes!
- That's what gave it up for me
- Yes it's really
- I'm like fighting, mmm
- Well I didn't wanna like
(Andre imitating punching sounds)
- There it is! There it is!
Likely story, likely story.
- Did you make a demo?
- Yeah I do have a demo.
- Dude I wanna see his demo.
(upbeat tense music)
- Hey!
(everyone clapping)
- Oo
- Okay. Go off.
- [Narrator] That is the
end of the game and we
want to thank you all for participating
and we want to give you all a gift.
- Aww
- I love toe bags!
- Thank you!
- Thank You.
- Yes, people get surprised when they find
out I'm a black belt.
I don't really volunteer the information.
- I love martial arts, I love teaching it.
I love being able to spread it.
- It doesn't matter what age you are,
what body size you are.
Anyone can become a black belt.
As long as you put the work to it.
- You guys did make one incorrect vote.
So I need to take half.
- Okay.
- Yeah
(upbeat hiphop music)
- Yay!
- Woo!
- Oh my money!
(upbeat hiphop music continues)
(women laughing)
(upbeat hiphop music ends)